you've been assassinated or something
there but i know he's been ill and he's
had to withdraw from the tournament but
okay we're off for the moves david yeah
we're off with the moves and it's
disappointing we can't seizure andrew
right now hopefully hopefully we can uh
get her camera back in a moment but it
is the queen's gambit
it's uh for the chess queen the women's
world champion and uh it's the queen's
gambit accepted so this is a variation
of the queen's camera accepted black
wonder porn temporarily white won the
pawn back so it's level material right
now and we are likely to see at some
point a very symmetrical pawn structure
and this is a very modern way of
treating it uh treating the queen's
camper accepted for white it looks very
very modest white has castle the king
white's just going to put pieces on very
natural squares and
take the battle to the middle game um
simon maybe you have more experience in
this type of structure than i do
as far as i know it's quite balanced
yeah not not really david i mean i i've
actually all struggled playing against
the queen's gambit accepted but i think
dominguez has done a chess ball course
on it am i right in thinking that so he
obviously knows the opening incredibly
well but uh the way they're playing the
speed they're playing it must all be
theory and i like what drew wendren has
done here guaranteeing a lovely square
for the white knight yeah
it is actually theory and up until now
they were following
up until this uh
porn move this a2 to a4 porn move
they were following a game that
dominguez had played himself that
dominguez had won but uh now they're in
different territory and uh dominguez
still playing very very quickly yeah
what's interesting to me is that
dominguez is playing instantly he's been
blitzing out all his moves but the
evaluation bar the computer really likes
white's position
so um maybe
dominguez just assumes that this is the
type of advantage that could fizzle out
if black is really accurate he can
neutralize
um white's activity simon this is the
square you were talking about right this
dream outpost for the white knight the
c4 square
um it's dynamite here c4 oh oh
just yeah
pin drop
i shouldn't have to explain my jokes but
uh yeah this white knight is uh on a
great
uh on a great square i've got to warm up
a little bit
just getting into the swing of things
thanks guys
and meanwhile black is castled so we're
finally at the end of the opening
after 14 moves we're out of the opening
and in the middle game
and uh well this kind of position is it
too early to say if it's like george is
it
something that could be quite dramatic i
think it's a great opening choice from
zhu and jun i'm slightly surprised
dominguez has gone into this because
white is super solid um even if there is
another trade of uh pawns in the center
i don't see too much going wrong for
white
it's roughly symmetrical
lots of pieces on the board white is
rock solid no weaknesses and i was going
to say beforehand zhu and jun she can
use this strategy against high rated
players especially players like
dominguez who they're far far behind on
the points right now they need to take
risks to beat her so she can just say
okay i'm going to be solid not take any
risks you're the one who's going to have
to gamble you're the one who's going to
have to
kind of come at me and risk everything
and that's how she beat players like
rapport yesterday how she beat way ye
they pressed too hard against her and
she just counter-attacked it's a really
good strategy because i mean uh in the
past when i've played higher-rated
players i've probably taken the other
strategy trying to mix it up trying to
complicate it trying to trying to do
something before they do but allowing
your opponent to come at you and to
overextend themselves is kind of like a
just a very good war strategy in general
isn't it allowing the opposition to try
too much and
it's working very well i mean she's a
great player and she's proven that
already
some exchanges in the middle here i mean
dominique is still playing at the speed
of light yeah and the way he's looking
so he was looking off to his left um
on towards the right on our screen but
he's looking off towards his left that
normally means a player is just trying
to memorize something so he's probably
studied this exact position before or
something very similar at least in the
right time and he's been playing so fast
and that means he's within his homework
still yeah and there are 20 games in the
database
and uh with great players playing them
we have alex um
i've forgotten his first name my mind is
gone black dreiff okay alex adrian
alexey dreyev yes uh he faced off
against ernest inakev and then we have
bulky productivity against roman edward
and again we'll have a list of just
grand masters all playing this opening
with both white and black
and the most popular response is
actually to capture back with the pawn
with the bishop but that's not the only
move
if white wants to initiate more trades
and this is why jew has taken a pause
she can also capture the knights which
she's actually played also another
popular choice and uh
knight takes knight that is again the
only move and now okay
you can capture the pawn with the bishop
or the queen both side both moves
totally viable yeah and uh if you take
with a bishop it looks like you have
nice control this bishop looks very
strong i guess if you take with the
queen you need an answer um there is a
big threat i should mention on the board
along this diagonal white's queen wants
to capture for example uh this pawn and
give checkmate that would be a very
nasty end to the game but
you do need an answer to this bishop
move
and has this been played before javanco
it has been played before and now get
this white has tried i don't know
whether it's a great move uh this all
the games that have been played in this
particular bishop position has ended in
a draw white zoomed to the edge of the
board to the a7 square and
counter-attack the bishop wow this would
be uh very very creative by zhu and jun
i don't think she has studied this exact
position so if she finds a maneuver like
this which is quite counter-intuitive
putting a queen on the edge of the board
then
fair play to her but okay she goes for
the more solid approach and i think this
is a good move too just taking back the
pawn with the bishop and these two
pieces stand great right now
you could definitely imagine a situation
where white just exchanges off black's
best bishop
on the next turn and then starts to
maybe try and get this rook into the
game
i slightly prefer white if anything how
about you guys
yeah i mean i think black still has to
try to equalize this position
if you just compare pieces
white's got this lovely knight
one of the problems that white does get
long term though is the c3 square maybe
we can highlight that one david um just
in the ending or later on if if black
can ever get a piece that square
especially the knight maybe after an
exchange of dark square bishops that
that can win the ending especially
because the white pawn next to it can
also be very very weak so uh there are
some sort of long-term problems uh that
white white can have in in this type of
position yeah long term as you mentioned
simon maybe this is the target if the
queens just uh disappear but uh
meanwhile what do you think of this move
dominguez again very very quickly he's
barely pausing for thought uh he just
pushes his pawn and this looks like a
bit of a target now the night uh the
night looking at this pawn the black
queen is going to be tied down defending
it for a long long time strange i must
say i'm a bit surprised by this and
either he's done his homework very very
deeply up to move 17 in a non-forcing
variation
or he's just trying to play by instinct
and he is a big expert on these types of
openings as simon mentioned so uh maybe
he understands a bit deeper than me here
yeah um
has been played before i mean again not
the most popular
position we've ever seen but uh we have
a swiss grand master noel studer he's
played this move twice
and also ivan sokolov very strong
grandmaster from holland has also played
this not without success though because
he did lose his game yeah all this name
dropping it's just like a list of grand
masters yeah i know
yes and i think we'll start that
challenge at some point uh someone was
saying name as many grandmasters as you
can in 30 seconds we need to start that
i mean the names you've been listing off
there ivanka those uh those should
feature on this list
yeah right now
in 30 seconds
and you have to sort of re-strategic
because i mean if you choose a lot of
for example the russians with these
super long names it takes too long you
need to
david howell for example that's a good
one to choose wesley so
yeah
then you can just do the surnames right
yeah that's pretty yeah so
and then yeah yeah you could do like van
faris and then you get two in one go
exactly
how will you get two yeah how are you
wow we actually need to set the rules
rates for this challenge coming later
coming later in the tournament but you
can start practicing
huh
that's true it looks like dominguez he's
trying to think right now how many
grandmasters can i name it how many
it would be cool to see the viewers do
it
is actually her last name that's a short
one too
yeah yeah yeah
and there's in i mean china you can i
mean
yeah i remember once getting called out
by anand i played a game against anand
and afterwards we were analyzing he was
like you've played this before i was
like no i haven't you played this before
no i haven't it's like no the chinese
grandmaster you played it
so you could just say you do yeah ding
ding ding
uh nguen
is also i don't know how to pronounce
that one i'm sure i've kind of have
totally but that's a common vietnamese
name yeah there's a few grandmasters
yeah something to work on
so so we know that that's the name with
only two letters are there any
grandmasters with only one letter in
their last name wow maybe i mean i'd
like to change my name just to x
simon x
not simon w
that's a bit boring isn't it x sounds a
bit more like yeah you know
bad kind of james bond villain doesn't
it you know live in my castle in the
city or saying no simon x no i think i
think it has to be two letters isn't it
which is can't be any one letter what
was the grandmaster
no it can't be what's the child of uh
elon musk yeah big chess fan at elon
musk yeah he always tweets about chess i
saw this picture of him in his uh school
chess club recently when he was young i
know yeah i think he said it was quite
challenging i think he said it was quite
a simple game though didn't he
in one of his tweets elon so he
obviously got that a little bit wrong
this is not a simple game this is
awesome this
but yeah i think his kids like x y 2 3
4.5 or something so
strange but maybe not the easiest
surname of a grand master to remember in
some countries you wouldn't be allowed
to name your child that
i remember tiger hill person was telling
me an interesting story ty goes from
sweden and he's one of the only swedish
people called tiger because you're not
allowed to give yourself you know you
can't call your kid the strange name
it's just not allowed so he had to his
mom had to get special permission
from the priest to be called tiger and
then he got and he was able to be you
know one of the only swedish people to
be able to you know call tiger so uh
yeah but you can get away with anything
nowadays can't you really change your
name uh in the us i think you can get
away with anything maybe in u.s yeah
yeah he has some very dodgy names
all the apples and the
yeah i have a great story but i'll tell
you after this after the show
happened to one of my sister's friends
in america
but anyway oh you can't you can't tease
us like that yeah well i'm gonna have to
because otherwise
i'm in trouble yes all right we do have
a rook move yeah we've had a couple of
moves since we last discussed the
position and not too much has changed i
guess it's just mainly that the dark
squared bishops are about to leave the
board
and uh a trade of dark squared bishops
i'm not 100 sure who that favors um
you would think in general that that
would favor black because white's bishop
in the middle of the board looks
fantastic but
it would help to activate white's rook
that has just moved if black would
initiate the exchange right now and
maybe we can jump in because
the move i want to play just because i'm
a caveman is a very direct threat i
would love for dominguez to pick up his
queen uh which is not doing too much and
play the move he's just played he
threatened checkmate on this square with
his queen
with his bishop uh this is a bit of a
weakness and zhu and june of course has
foreseen this and she just dropped back
her bishop to defend and the reason i
like this for black is because not only
are you looking down at the white king
but also from the square you might be
protecting
um this weak pawn that i highlighted a
bit earlier so just indirectly
protecting it at some point and again
big question what does black play here
can you just move your rook across do
you maybe move the bishop into the
center at some point do you trade a set
of bishops if you trade then maybe that
helps white i don't know this rook looks
pretty good right now
it's a lot of questions actually a lot
of choice in the current position for
black
what do you guys think what's the first
move that jumps out
to you
i was just trying to think in positions
like this obviously you mentioned
there's a lot of exchanges which are
possible
and it's kind of like which pieces do
you want to exchange i think it's always
worth asking yourself that question so
if you're playing on the black side of
this position what minor pieces do i
want to get off the board and i think
you're right i think you're right dave
well you know you normally are when you
say when you say the bishops come off
and you swapped them off that helps
black it's it seems like that's a great
exchange and i'd even be trying to swap
off well white's knight seems like such
a powerful piece but i don't really want
to exchange my night off for it because
i can see the black knight having
potential
i'm wondering about swapping my bishop
off that night but not convinced by that
either so uh so i i don't know they both
have good pieces don't they in this
position yeah it could be a case of
knights versus bishops as you mentioned
there is an idea of maybe planting the
bishop in and then taking this knight or
at least hinting at it uh at some moment
and it's that maneuver you mentioned
earlier simon that really attracts me
i'm not sure right now or a bit later
but at some point trying to jump into
this beautiful outpost that black has
secured for himself now the dart squad
bishops are off the board wide start
squares are slightly weak so i'm
expecting to see uh that happen from
dominguez next move meanwhile we have
seen june june pause after this bishop
capture is she really thinking of taking
back this bishop with the pawn the
reason we didn't even mention that
really is because this pawn is simply
isolated
it's not going to go anywhere anytime
soon it can be blockaded on the square
in front of it by black's bishop or
black's knight for example with a bishop
now
or with a knight maybe even stronger
jumping into the square so it's really
surprising that zhu wenjun has paused
for thought right now
she spotted something else i mean you
have to take this bishop back yeah
absolutely um just wondering whether if
we can pull up her camera maybe it's
just an issue of the computer freezing
or
no she's just thinking
um yeah
very strange
decision because you do not want to
capture that bishop with the porn as
david's highlighted
and uh she be tr uh extra sneaky extra
tricky and try and push harry the h pawn
maybe yeah i mean i did just cheat by
looking at the computer and it's kind of
like it just seems like you can get away
with that move so often
you can get away with it i think yeah
it's unbelievable what a fine there
david
i mean yeah i'm just trying to get into
her head and the only explanation for
her pausing to think here because rook
takes bishop is such an obvious move is
that she wants to counter attack instead
of grabbing the bishop she wants to hit
the black queen and
okay let's get the board up because this
is such a key moment and let's
definitely keep an eye on jewendren's
camera because simon you confirm that
pushing harry the h pawn you can do it
in nearly any position uh it looks like
you just have to recapture a bishop but
first you can hit the black queen it
looks like you're giving a pawn away but
if the queen takes the pawn then you've
actually tricked her you've lured the
queen onto a bad square and suddenly
you're hitting the queen and you're
hitting the knight at the same time
the black queen has to zoom back to
protect her knight and suddenly after
the white queen moves i'm not sure
exactly what square um then again you
can hit the knight using the rook and
queen and you've unpinned your own
knight so next move when black defends
the knight you can maybe go and grab
this pawn
hanging on the edge of the board and i
mean this is two or three moves deep and
he's played
for it that's quite incredible she found
that move it's so i think most people
would just grab that bishop without
thinking they would not i mean even me i
love pushing that board i would not
think about pushing it here so uh
you know very interesting move played it
just shows such great awareness right
just looking for every option in on
every move full board awareness but it
also shows such kind of
self-control
as simon says in this position i would
just think okay i'd pre-move almost rook
takes bishop move on look for the next
move but uh just to
kind of expand your horizons and even
find a move like this one pawn to h4
hitting the black queen and big dilemma
now what does dominguez do with this
black queen maybe he doesn't want to put
it on the edge of the board where it
will get hit by the white rook
uh and if he doesn't put it on the edge
of the board then where's it go
it needs to ideally protect this pawn uh
over the next few turns and that pawn is
going to be a big big weakness yeah i
mean maybe just retreat it david to that
sensible square and then try to play the
night maneuver that you mentioned i mean
that the long-term problem uh i think
are on white side here if that black
knight can just slide into white's
position
as the route you're showing here that is
a really problematic square in the long
run uh because you cannot you cannot
really get rid of that black knight i
mean the white knight can be exchanged
but that black knight just can't ever be
exchanged by a minor piece because the
white bishop is on the wrong square so i
i think i think it's fairly even i i
would say i don't know what you think
ivanka i mean it looks
fairly even to me
at the moment but a lot of play in the
position yeah
i have to say
because i i'm i really like counter
attacks i actually don't like white's
position at all and i'm just saying this
right now i think it's okay white is
safe but i can just envisage a future
where this pawn on h4 might be a little
bit of a liability and when i compare
the bishops i'm thinking black's bishop
is amazing why is bishop just completely
defensive piece and all black needs to
do is maybe just put a rook on to the
fifth row and
again put the knight into the dream
square and then you know you start
looking at you like oh well black has
got the initiative there so maybe
you know maybe i'm just a bit too future
focused maybe not living in the present
but um i'm a little bit concerned
actually that things can go the wrong
way are you a saver do you save your
money rather than spend it no do you
like you have your piggy bank put the
pound coins in since you're two years
old no no i'm not a saver at all now
okay so you you don't play chess like
you live life because one thing i've
noticed a lot of people live life like
they play chess right you know you have
crazy sacrificial players they're a bit
of a lunatic
you know you're safe and steady players
and they're a bit more like what am i
what we're going to eat tomorrow you
know kind of players so would you say
you're like you know do that i mean what
kind of player would you say you are
i would say i'm probably
more on the side of careful but i i am a
little bit
instinctive so are you a careful person
yes in some things you had to think
about it i know i very carefully thought
about the answer there yeah i did i did
i did i know which category you fall
into simon yeah does it matter maybe
let's not go there
and what about you david
you know you played you've got a very
unique style of playing like you you
love the grinding the torture
yeah the long
my heaven the game
but uh yeah when i was younger i used to
be more just kind of carefree i just
wanted to attack and i thought checkmate
was the only way to end the game but now
i realize there's a lot more uh
finesse to it too do you live your life
as you play jazz do i grind in real life
as well
it's all about the long game
haven't you got a course coming out um
with with the word grind in it is that
right is this a dance course or uh uh
it's a no it's a chessable course simon
what's it called uh grind like a
grandmaster
are you gonna be pulling some moves in
it like yeah
yours will have to buy it
may not be some uh slick moves oh it's
gonna be in line now to get that
adjustable course it's not out yet but
it's coming it's coming but it is a
question right and we should put that
question to everyone watching you know
do you play chess the way you live your
life you know are you carefree are you a
saver are you caught are you cautious
yeah are you a gambler i don't want to
know you can uh tweet us using the
hashtag chesschamps i agree i think that
must be the best name for a chess course
so far it's quite unique grind like a
grand master i like it so very special
course as well yeah we're gonna have to
buy it i can't wait for it to be
finished and uh yeah for it to come out
and uh game six in the world chess
championship match in dubai is featured
that was a very long grinding game and
later today david is going to take us
through game six in the 1972 world
championship match was that a grind as
well or was it crazy in another sense
that was a different kind of grind maybe
um it was just i mean it was a
masterpiece from fisher both his opening
choice which really surprised sebastian
then his middle game was just artistic
kind of seizing control over the whole
board he had a complete domination at
some point and then um the finish was a
bit more brutal than most grinds
but uh yeah i think that's regarded as
one of fish's greatest ever games and
one of the greatest games in world
championship history buskie even
applauded him after the game yeah
spassky the gentleman he knew that in
that game fisher really showed his uh
his quality yeah that's a also quite an
interesting uh story when it came to
spassky's preparation for the match uh
you know he was convinced that bobby
fisher would only open with one move
that was pushed the king's ball forward
and when his uh coaches and sakan said
you know
let's look at your what you have against
the queen's gambit he goes no no no i
don't need to study because i'm just
going to play this opening called
tartakova
and uh where did he lose
in his beloved tatakova wow
um okay
that would never happen nowadays
nowadays all the top players know a bit
about every opening they have plans
everywhere uh in those days they just
prepared against one move and
either the preparation worked or you
were on your own wow to freestyle well
after a long pause lenia dominguez did
retreat his uh queen and we do see the
the position that you predicted david on
the board yeah and this is where simon
mentioned just a very calm move black
knight re-routing
and uh okay he doesn't go for that very
calm move he instead attacks the white
rook and this is logical in some way the
white rook looks pretty good on this
fourth rank but pushing this for this
pawn forward does leave some looseness
in black's position there's no longer a
square for the black knight to use or
maybe a less stable square for the black
knight to use in the center
um i've got mixed feelings about this
one it looks decent for now but i could
see it backfiring later if you have to
be very careful pushing pawns don't you
because they're the only bits that can't
go backwards and when you push a pawn
you always weaken squares and uh both
the squares on either side of that pawn
are now weakened and as you mentioned
david the black knight might be a bit
looser but also the white queen has
maybe an aggressive square it can get
out the pin
now maybe it could even jump in there at
this moment in time
potentially yeah you mentioned the queen
jump and
um that's why pushing pawns i mean this
pawn no longer has grip over this f5
square a white knight would love to land
on this square but
um this is a double attack
how does black deal with this does he
have to jump out the way with his knight
again the knight is attacked twice
this queen looks beautiful but i i guess
zhu and jun would need a follow-up
and i didn't see one right now
maybe this is what dominguez is thinking
he's uh just banking on the fact that
the white queen can't get active but
it's kind of false activity it looks
nice and pretty but it's not achieving
too much also you've got to be careful
the white queen doesn't get trapped
by the black bishop at some point
i have cheated
um which i'll try not to do but you know
it's my first day back i'll take it easy
there's some funny case of that in chess
which maybe we mentioned later but
there's an amazing idea here which the
computer gives and the computer gives i
think i just have to mention it going
queen d3 oh in my current position in
the current position which which makes a
lot of sense you're getting the queen
out of the pin you're attacking the
knight now i don't know what happens the
knight moves but um the main line it
gives is bishop d5 for example and now
queen takes bishop whoa which is an
incredible positional idea i assume
the queen and it says it's very good for
white uh this variation i don't know how
strong this computer is maybe the
computer
i'll just check this laptop a little bit
make sure make sure it's working
properly because it looks a little bit
wonky doesn't it that idea but
it's a very interesting we love a queen
sack so it's a very interesting idea at
least yeah so giving up the queen but in
return you get a rook and you have a
bishop um so it's not a massive material
sacrifice and i guess the justification
is that you're going to win this pawn
that's guaranteed and once you win this
pawn for example if black moves once you
take this pawn then white a porn is a
passport it's going to start advancing
and we could see it you know because
she's moved her queen to attack the
knight and
if dominguez intercepts that attack with
the bishop then maybe but i mean even
the rook ivanka i guess as well
because if the rook moves to hit the
queen you don't want to run away you
don't want to step back and retreat it's
an incredible idea she plays i mean if
she finds this idea she's
it's an incredible idea isn't it i mean
i don't know how many people have seen
h4 and this idea of giving up the queen
though yeah it's uh brilliant
i mean if dominguez moves his knight
which is attacked right now instead then
the white queen can still jump into the
position maybe uh yeah i mean i really
hope he's just going to block on this
square so we can see that beautiful
queen sacrifice from the women's world
champion it takes a lot of guts to
sacrifice your queen even the even if
you do get material in exchange
so what kind of personality
let's keep an eye on the players because
queen takes bishop would be an amazing
move right now yeah oh she plays this
it's a round of applause move yeah if
she plays this and wins the game which
she might well do and i guess black's
queen is just not really
too active right now so this type of
sacrifice would be justified and
she looks very interested in the
position yeah so tempted queen takes
bishop giving up the queen
getting this really powerful rook you
will win this pawn
so you will get a bishop a rook and a
pawn for the queen that's level material
anyway yeah i mean i was just wondering
david if black can move the knight to
next to the rook here that's the only
move i'm thinking i'd be a little bit
worried about but maybe it just doesn't
help maybe you just you just take the
pawn attack the knight and white's
pieces control the ball don't they and
this is where uh they're dominating the
queen so it's it's a very clever idea i
just hope she plays it now she gets
control of the light squares and
everything and i love it
i was going to ask how tempting is it to
push the pawn as well and attack
oh what a golden chance
yeah i should i she was surely thinking
about it there surely
maybe if it wasn't a rapid game if she
had more than three minutes on the clock
she would have uh spent more time
looking at it at least now she's not
giving up a queen she's simply trying to
swap off the queen's exchange the queens
which makes sense as well but she will
lose a bit of time for example if black
says no shuts the door and just pushes
the pawn forward blocking the queen
trade
and uh when the white queen moves i'm
not sure where then i think black should
be completely fine now
actually i'm not sure about this square
um sorry
miss click there but
yeah in this position it feels like
black should be fine
um just
simply no way through the black pieces
actually guard a lot of entry squares
now
yeah
missed opportunity maybe yeah what kind
of what kind of a person can we get
anything from her personality from the
way they're playing uh do we feel i mean
uh dominguez is very booked up quite
quite tactical player but quite safe but
he's very well um
i don't know researched yeah so um i i
mean and g wing jun we'd say is a great
attacking player but tactical vision is
very good i mean i don't know it'd be
interesting
if we could gather anything about their
personality from the way they play yeah
i'd be inclined to agree with you simon
i mean lania dominguez super super
talented
the best cuban player since kappa blanca
but uh okay now i'm playing for the u.s
but i mean he supplemented his kind of
talent with so much hard work
i know that the english number one
michael adams
whenever we're playing in team
tournaments whenever we used to play
cuba he would be like oh no i have to
play dominguez
his openings are too good
and uh yeah he nearly never loses at
least in classical chess
that's interesting here because i can't
really imagine mickey adams you know
england's maybe england's greatest ever
player being scared of anyone so uh it's
quite you know he can be scared it gives
us a bit of hope so
um but yeah dominguez is just really
he's incredibly strong player i think
he's been blitzwell champion before
maybe as well so
um you know a number of years ago
i mean you have to have good instincts
to pick on uh blitzwolf and of course
you know we mustn't forget that he's a
long-time second of fabiana caruana
helped him challenge for the crown in
2018 so you know very well prepared a
very very strong grand master
and uh juwen june of course she's the
women's world champion yeah and uh
i was trying to recall who's helping her
actually
she has a team behind her as well
probably most of the children i'm
thinking
is that
possibly uh i mean he's coached a lot of
uh
over the top and she's got a smile on
her face yeah she's pretty happy with
that
yeah
curious what is she thinking about he's
just loving this white rook that's just
lifted up the board just enjoying the
fact it's in black's position that'd be
really disconcerting if you're playing
someone though there was this russian
grand master i won't mention his name
actually but he played in england quite
a lot and he would do that very often he
would just start smiling you know you're
playing him and you're like what have i
done what have i done it'd be like
why is he smiling it would be a little
bit odd i think you know so but it's
good to see them enjoying themselves as
well notice she does this though i've
sat next to her a few times in
tournaments and she's always smiling
yeah it's great yeah
enjoying the moment yeah no sometimes
it's all about uh as david says just
managing to just crack a smile and enjoy
the situation that you're in i did it
once when i was totally lost
and i was i had a horrible position i
could barely move i didn't you know my
opponent had so many winning plans and i
just looked outside i was playing in a
ski resort in norway and i thought
life is beautiful actually
look at how lucky i am and i started
smiling and i'm sure everyone who walked
past would have gone wide
and then then i looked down on my
position i thought actually i had one
trick that i could try to set up and so
i set that up and
my grandmaster opponent fell for it and
then the smile continued
yeah
yeah i know i mean you know she's
enjoying herself it's nice to see that a
bit of emotion over the over the board
there
um
this looks like lovely square david for
the rook i mean the one that it's moved
into and seems like she has a little bit
of pressure maybe here right dominguez
definitely thinking he is now for the
first time in the game under do you want
you on the clock yeah it's because black
has the questions to answer right now
white's rook is super active black's
rooks look good but they are just
blocked out by the white knight so
they're kind of staring against this
kind of rock-solid statue this knight
which is well fortified and white's rook
can maybe zoom across to the a file to
start looking at black's
weakness that we've been talking about
on the a5 square that weak pawn white's
other rook can slide across white can
double up rooks hit the black knight
meanwhile what does black do maybe black
can centralize the king that would be
first thing on my radar but
at some point dominguez is going to have
to answer the question what is he going
to do with the black knight now there's
no path into the position like simon was
highlighting earlier okay he does
centralize his king this is maybe the
most logical move um that's the only
piece not not participating
but how is black's night going to get
into the position how are you ever going
to get rid of white's knight if you ever
traded off with black's bishop then
white's bishop suddenly becomes
a strong piece as well just replaces the
white knight
oh it would be so tempting now to just
go across with the white rook
i'm also wondering what black's next
move is this is a really good thing to
do that not enough lower rated players
do
they're only thinking about their own
ideas and i think the the
the basic step you can do to improve
your game is to think about what your
opponent's next move was and just in
that last position i couldn't really
see a very good move for black
but it's a good way to think but okay
interesting maneuver happened on there
yeah can she win a pawn yeah i'm just
thinking can you not step
forward or just take the pawn as uh
yeah yeah i mean it looks like she can
just get greedy right now yeah and uh
she has a couple of ways with which to
do this it looks like it's all gone
wrong for dominguez in the current
position um if we just backtrack to show
what was happening as simon mentioned
black belly has a move here right black
is struggling to find a move but she
decided to be direct attacking this pawn
with her rook and after the black knight
retreats hitting this rook
first of all if if in doubt just give a
check you don't have to rush you can
give a check and then decide what to do
next move
but uh also the big question can you
just
go uh guzzle up this porn
rook takes porn
if uh rook takes rook yes your knight's
temporarily offside maybe dominguez's
idea is to get the black rook into the
position but
you have won a pawn it feels like it
should be good for white somehow okay
she does give a check instead but this
pawn is gonna drop
dominguez's idea is to offer a trade of
rooks and
his yeah he must be banking on the fact
that here he can get active with his
rook otherwise there's no other
justification
i mean if white gets time for example to
just drop back with the knight or maybe
even come forward with the bishop it's
just a clear pawn and black's pieces are
still passive
so his whole idea is to get active
and are we going to see this happen on
the board is she going to get greedy and
grab a pawn i think she needs to and
here we go
the rook is now attacking this pawn with
the bishop
and what to do here big question she's
done the hard work she's one uh very
important pawn but
what's next
yeah i mean i guess the first thought
would be to move the bishop but
i mean you can try to swap the bishops
off maybe but it does come with a little
bit of risk i think as well
because
let's say black exchange is a bishop we
can show this now you kind of want to
take the knight
um but maybe now black's knight can
activate and
things
it seems like black's getting a bit
active maybe i don't know there's still
a bit of danger here maybe i mean
i i know
yeah that's that that's a
little bit a little bit dangerous right
yeah another very tempting uh idea in
the current position yes this pawn is
attacked but um i'm just thinking of the
time that you tricked us simon this
black knight is on the back rank and uh
you could kind of fix it in the night
stable you could uh bring the bishop
forward just try to lock this knight in
look how the bishop dominates the night
the knight has nowhere to go but i guess
it would come at the cost of giving back
your pawn okay she does offer a trade of
bishops i was going to say here you give
back your pawn but at least your bishop
is dominating the black knight right now
i'm not sure whether this is uh enough
instead
ah we didn't see the night stable i'm a
bit gutted about that but bishop takes
uh bishop and key moment we mentioned
knight takes maybe allowing the black
knight to come out is she going to take
the pawn maybe
it's possible right
you do give black a pass pawn though and
you do allow black to maybe go behind
and win this guy
yeah suddenly it's less clear yeah kind
of feels like black is just active
enough
to sort of uh have at least good holding
chances here
could be wrong of course but now i i
guess this this is a position i was a
little bit worried for ju wengen if
dominguez just brings his knight out
there are other options of course um but
bringing the knight improving your
pieces defending your central pawn there
keeping the frets going just looks so
natural to play this move quickly and
they're both getting quite short time
right so they're gonna have to start
picking up the pace soon i think that's
a great move simon uh bringing the
knight out into the game uh the problem
is if you take this pawn as black then
you do have to worry about white
grabbing another pawn okay he has done
this
at least now i was going to say the
black knight is once again dominated by
white tonight but at least now dominguez
has the idea of going after white's
remaining queenside porn
so uh are we gonna see the hoover come
out everything disappear
or can drew and june work some magic and
grind out this end game
it's uh i do wonder and okay so we're
actually gonna see this um and uh he
doesn't go for the a pawn instead so i
wonder whether he was afraid that maybe
white's rook is going to get active yeah
but uh
what's to stop the white rook
i'm thinking of transferring it to the
fifth
fifth row and then trying to get behind
the pawn i like that it's a very nice
idea i think yeah
best place to if your opponent's got a
pass pawn you're starting to get worried
about
and it's a rook ending i think and this
is a great idea of anchor getting your
rook behind your opponent's passport is
the ideal situation well worth
remembering and the rook is very active
there that's a lovely maneuver actually
yeah it looks very very good and uh you
will gain time against this black knight
in the process for example
if the bomb pushes forward you hit the
black knight and where is it actually
going
it doesn't really want to sit on the
edge of the board it looks pretty bad
there temporarily at least
and uh if it goes forward you can pin it
and win it
would this make it into your if jew
engine wins your grind like a grand
master course maybe yeah because part
two maybe it could be a puzzle right it
could be i mean there's definitely some
grinding going on here
with with white it's the porn up still
if she wins in 100 moves i'll uh
nominate it
it's gonna be 100 moves to get in your
course yeah it's going to be
over
68 plus one moves
69
yeah it's going to be a long endgame
grind you have to show you have to win
by outlasting your opponent by tiring
them out and yeah by eking out these
small advantages
and uh okay the black knight now on the
edge of the board we mentioned that this
isn't a great piece and
maybe it's trying to get back into the
game
how can we stop it from uh not using
that square but using this square
yeah so it's just pushed on and um
yeah it's gonna they're gonna have to i
mean calculation is very important these
type of endings as well because they
both got dangerous past pawns so you
assume when you get to an ending you
know calculation is not so important but
in actual fact it can be more important
and it's it's a good thing to train in
simple tactics in the ending i mean can
can the black knight now come in david
do you think or is that too risky
yeah i think the black knight would love
to come in but yeah you definitely have
to calculate whether white's a porn is
now the more dangerous of the two past
pawns
it might be time to
perhaps
um i was going to say introduce new
pieces into the
into the game maybe black can
activate the king but that's actually
very difficult and so lenier goes for
your night activation move
but
a very tricky position actually very
very hard to calculate this who's porn
is stronger that's the big question
white's rook i love where it's placed
right now but
how can you increase the pressure
i kind of like this maneuver maybe maybe
centralizing that night or or maybe
trying to use it to support the pawn
obviously when i say i like that move
the computer completely drops
as always but it seems very logical to
put the knight in in the center of the
board yeah very very logical and uh some
tricky night jumps as well some tricky
checks black's king has to be really
careful where it goes actually
what does black play if black's knight
moves if black's knight for example goes
and grabs white central pawn then
black's past born the b pawn will drop
i don't think you want to make that
exchange ideally definitely not you know
i always say in the endgame it's not
about the quantity of pawns it's the
quality of the pawns and by that i just
means that how far advanced up the board
you know whether they are supported
where they can even move forward so
always never judge by the quantity
judged by how good they are
and uh
yeah
it's it's difficult because at the same
time lenient has to guard against the
night check so maybe
maybe it's time for taking some
precautions there
try to control the white knight but that
kind of also feels like it's the wrong
direction
uh such a hard position yeah yeah i mean
okay this seems kind of sensible that
night was very strong try to give it a
kick away
um i think that's a good move
yeah and where is white's knight going
to run to
well suddenly it's it's still all
through results possible i mean we
talked about she went through grinding
out this win uh not we not really talked
about her being in trouble but if she
put something white knight on a passive
square
suddenly black's pieces could be uh
taking control 44 seconds david as well
this is quite worrying i mean we know
how good dominguez is uh in it blitz
being the well x world champion and so
ju when jun is there's a little bit of
danger here that this this could go
wrong you're right david i think and
she's gotta
play quickly 30 seconds on the clock
yeah
and she's shaking her head yeah and she
doesn't quite know where to put the
knight um in this kind of case i guess
could you argue for maybe tracking the
king gain some time on the clock
an extra 10 seconds and then decide what
to do with the night i think she's
panicking a bit there yeah sure you
could say when you're when you're
shaking your head and you've got 20
seconds left not a good idea she's got
less she's got five
four move three okay she gives a check
just in time yeah so when in doubt give
a check that tends to be a good strategy
the black king forced to make a
difficult decision it didn't step into
the center that would have been maybe
more ambitious but also more risky uh
stepping down the board instead it
retreats and she's
created a threat june june the white
knight wants to leap forward now giving
a check to the black king
forking also the black rook a double
attack
so black's rook or king need to move one
of the two
oh which one do you just move maybe the
black king towards the white rook
that makes sense ah i mean just getting
out of any potential checks
and also stop keeping an eye on the
white pawn uh the a pawns making sure
that it doesn't advance further yeah i
mean that would be the first move on my
radar but there might be a downside to
that move the white knight might jump
forward anyway i think she's found a
good solution at least a safe solution
uh asking some questions of dominguez
and uh he looks so calm he looks so
focused
what do you think will we see a winner
in this
game it's still definitely possible all
three results possible
i'm thinking that you know and i i i
just looking at the camera looking at
the body language i see that jew is
maybe in a little bit of a panic mode
she's getting stressed by the clock
meanwhile uh lenier just looked like
he's uh in his elements you know
completely unfazed but then again june
june with a few seconds on the clock
she's managed to beat rapport beat uh
yi she's beaten several players while
playing on the increment and dominguez
has made a couple of mistakes one long
time in the tournament so the calm
exterior might be i look at the timer
under 20 seconds of course it caught her
up on time so
i think that was a great as you said
david a great idea the check and the
night come back really just clever way
of stabilizing and and now it's
dominguez
who's in real trouble
three
he needs to move the king of the road
okay he moves the king
okay shuffles across
very logical i'm expecting white tonight
now to jump forward attacking the black
rook again creating two threats one to
take the black rook the other one is for
the white rook to slide across in front
of the black king give a check and
attack the black knight so okay black
had to defend his knight
what has zhu and jun got up her sleeve
now she's created some really nice
tricks
can she get greedy go grab some pawns is
she going to give a check with the white
rook okay she tucks her king to the edge
of the board
and now her rook is attacked by the
black knight
black's pawn does look very scary though
no they can advance one square
max porn can advance one square but then
white's pawn is gonna start running his
pawn is stronger i think it's your
ivanka your brook maneuver again the
white rook behind that pawn is so key
isn't it in this position the white rook
such a strong piece and uh it does stop
that pawn four three two
oh
he's lost a lot of time by doing that
he's lost time on the clock and on the
board yeah
or it's going a little bit up for jew
when jude
i know and the position is still really
unclear with both sides having those
past pawns
and again seven seconds for the chinese
women's world champion and uh now she
gets greedy
okay this is risky this is white white
sir knight is so far away from the
action now wow there we go the
evaluation yeah sorry david
i was just saying it's going crazy isn't
it
yeah and black now does he use his rook
and go across go after white's fire
advanced pawn
that to me is the first instinct
whiteboard is too strong you have to go
and stop it
both sides using rooks behind the
opponent's pawns it's really instructive
maybe now is the time time to give a
check with the work to the king ask some
questions because a bailout oh that was
a bad move according to the bar at the
moment um
check where's black skin going it's
going forward of course i'm just
wondering whether you can kind of try to
bail out and try to just give up your
night and uh win the past b pawn
okay so white tonight gave a check will
it give another check
it's just offside she got greedy just
for one moment so she's currently two
pawns up but it's all about black's
passport now being much stronger than
the counterpart
and okay this check is desperation i
think she just wants to get her knight
back into play but black's king is super
active
black's pieces have taken control
is there still some hope you know now
okay setting a little trick if dominguez
is tempted and just grabs that pawn with
his rook hoping to decoy the white rook
unfortunately that's not possible
because there is a check with the knight
to the c6 square such a such a naughty
trick
that one is i mean that's the kind of
thing anyone could fall into maybe we
could show it on the board quickly
because dominguez is he going to fall
into this trap is he going to take this
pawn at your vanco mentions trying to
distract the white rook so that black
make a queen but this would blunder into
a nasty night fork and uh he can't play
this he needs to find something else
maybe move the black king across he's
doing the night stable with the king
yeah dominating the knight controlling
any squares it wants to go to
really really strong move from there
from dominguez and maybe that spells the
end for zhu and jun now white's knight
is just a terrible piece on the edge of
the board knights on the rim are dim and
this knight is again on the rim
oh there's no way to get it out
which is so unfortunate you can get it
out this way but it's just far away from
all the action all the action is about
this pawn
black's knight is a monster meanwhile
okay she gives a check the black king
just sidesteps
and uh now you have to stop this pawn
you have to go back where you came from
but this is just game over once you go
back where you came from the black
knight
okay she gives a check i was gonna say
the black knight blocks and you make a
new queen next move she gives a check
instead and what is happening here the
black knight blocks again and black is
making a new queen
it looks like game over for zhu and june
unfortunately
uh
no way to stop black making a new queen
oh heartbreak yeah heartbreak for the
women's world champion yeah it just goes
to show the effect of the clock
and a new queen is on the board but okay
it doesn't and doesn't change anything
black is still completely winning yeah
unfortunately a knight and two pawns is
not enough compensation for a queen
and yeah she'll give a few checks she
might try and grab another pawn was uh
with her knight but
no more chances
well
all the other games that have finished
so far have ended with
draws
it looks like young christophe duda is
about to win against arjun edegaisi i've
seen the bar all the way over to the
young indian side all game so that must
have been a dramatic one duda shifting
it around and maybe about to win two of
the young players towards the top of the
table june june she had a fantastic day
yesterday
but it looks like she is about to lose
too lenia dominguez who is fighting hard
to qualify he only has five points
before this round so it's looking really
hard for him but three points will be
very important for him in this game and
aryan tari just won his game against
radus lavoitacek three points for the
norwegian
yeah this is heartbreaking i was just
looking she played so well for
45 moves and just one mistake
that cost her in this game but dominguez
yeah maybe he'll launch a comeback now
yeah i shall save the black king
yeah it's when the time started to get
low um jew engine just went a little bit
wrong there so easy to do uh you know to
to
even in these end game positions they
can be tactically so complicated that's
that's the end
we have a result she has resigned